so up first we have John mount he's
gonna talk about data algebra but let me
before we go into the talks let me talk
about how this is gonna work we have our
timer here j.j we're gonna give
everybody six minutes because we only
had six people sign up we have time to
do that and then I'm going to completely
abuse my role as moderator to take the
last spot of six minutes then so John's
gonna speak for six J's gonna count him
down when he gets to here this is 30
seconds left when he gets to here this
is time and I want everybody when you
see Jays fist in the air everybody start
applauding that is your yes then it is
like the Oscars you are being played off
the stage and you need to get off so
that the next person can come on because
I only want to have one minute between
each time I have ambitions so John is
gonna start first he's got six minutes
and then up next we'll have as Leland
McGinnis here Leland will go next all
right to you
start time thank you my name is John
mount and I want to talk about something
really quickly that we're developing at
art group wind vector called the data
algebra and it's kind of in the count
your fingers after you shake its hand a
stage so it's an early phase project but
it's something we've used a lot and
we're kind of proud of so quick outline
what is the data algebra work a horrific
example where we are with this project
and some links basically the links are
easy look for wind vector blog we'll put
up all the slides so you don't need to
write anything down we'll post this
tonight so what is the data algebra it's
a package for building up complex data
queries it's basically a lot like deep
liar if you're from the our world and
it's basically the idea is what if we
made queries data queries like
transformations adding an extra column
to a data set selecting a subset of rows
of a data set
joining two data sets summarizing a data
set or appending in a summary what if we
made those first-order operations that
we say stacking these operations is
important the data is an irrelevance II
that will enter into later and how did I
pick that set of operations well I'm
picking I'm
running through Cod's relational algebra
what he considered the important data
operations and I think that's sort of an
uncelebrated backbone of a lot of our
data processing even in the no sequel or
non sequel worlds is that that small set
of operations that God selected
essentially joining unioning selecting
appending rows appending summaries he
missed window functions but we'll put
those back in I think those are
basically the things that are important
so the operators in the algebra are
those composition we write left to right
the data starts on the left and moves
through the operators to the right so we
don't get this weird sequel ISM where
composition is built by ugly nesting
that a queries deep inside other queries
and actually I kind of lied there I
don't compose over the data what enters
in is the description of the data and
the idea is because a description enters
in now let's be a live room what's a
classic Cod description of data a schema
so basically data algebra takes in a
schema and produces a set of operations
that produces a resulting schema and we
can compose data algae operations if the
schemas match so basically if you're
saying simply y equals x plus 1 is there
an X column present and that's what lets
us treat the queries is first order
first class citizens things we can keep
around for a long time and reuse because
again when we're doing data science we
always apply all the operations to our
training data and then later to our test
your application data so we never ever
want to do the operations just once and
the idea is since the representation is
pretty neutral it can execute directly
on pandas or it can later omit sequel
and that's all implemented and we're
basically playing with modin and Rapids
and others but we haven't really got
that part working yet but this is what
the data algebra looks like and this is
the total meat of the talk that the
blurry top thing is a panda's data frame
then the blurry next line after that is
a table description is described that
table all it does is says I'm a table
that has columns GX and V essentially
schema ties is it now once we have that
schema we say an operation is a table
description piped into an extend node
piped into I'm saying pipe what we're
doing is met
the chaining when I say pipe I mean that
dot backslash and what comes back is a
query representation table descriptions
of query representation each and every
one of these is a larger table sorry
query representation and the extend is
what Cod would have named adding a
column or it is what he named adding a
column and what we're saying is that
order by the variable X and partition by
G so we're basically doing a window
function that we're gonna add in per
group summaries into the original data
frame it skips having to build a summary
data frame and then joining and then the
next one is a an extend that has a
partition but no order constraint and
then it just builds this table takes
this real tiny table it only had GX and
V and it builds this table that has the
other columns such as lagged variables
per group summaries per group summaries
is my absolute favorite in data science
because how do you know whether you're
big or large relative to your group well
the easiest way would be if somebody
would land your group mean as a column
and then you just compute the difference
so data algebra
everything is written into these tiny
little steps but they're very easy to
reason about and then at the end you
expose it to data using the transform
method or if you don't want to expose it
to data you say omit sequel and then you
admit the horrific a large sequel that
this represents so where are we the code
works well enough that we're using it
for internal projects we also use it's
our siblings our query and our cue data
table which are also our product when
vector LLC on our internal projects we
haven't inflicted it on that many users
and yet and we've had to completely
avoid it in our new book practical data
science in our because we don't want to
teach anybody something weird yeah you
don't want to wrap up people for failure
and we're looking to extend it to other
things GaN sequel beyond pandas maybe
Modan maybe Rapids things like that so
here are the links so basically
everything can be found by just knowing
write groups name is win vector the
projects on github it's available
through pi pi we have an introduction to
it here and we're building up that it
has a nice category theoretical
interpretation and let's do the fist
thank you I'm glad that the extra minute
seems to be a helping people out get to
the end of there
[ __ ] so Leland is up next we're gonna
have an Murray full sir topic modeling
is to model a corpus of documents in
terms of some sort of underlying topics
that describe the documents all right so
I'm just gonna turn all of that into
matrix factorization really really
quickly so the goal of matrix
factorization I've got a big matrix of
data that might be a bag of words model
of a document where it's just counts of
how many times each word which your
features occur in each document which
are your rows and I'm gonna represent
that as two smaller matrices multiplied
together as closely as possible
that's matrix factorization so we've got
the data the rid section there is your
low dimensional representation of the
data and the green stuff is the
archetypes which in err case would be
the topics so what we're really saying
is that a row or a document is
represented as this representation times
the archetypes so in other words we're
describing that as a linear combination
of these topics so a document is a
linear combination of topics and that's
really all we're doing so that's topic
modeling as matrix factorization very
quickly so linear latent dirichlet
allocation and pls a are a couple of
probabilistic matrix factorization
methods that are common ways to do this
well latent directly allocation is the
common way to do this pls a is the less
common one that I'm going to use and
explain okay
what I want to do is ensembles of pls I
will get there in a minute though
so first of all why am I using pls a
performance so I wrote an implementation
of pls a using number to get really fast
performance out of it and the result of
that is that using the scikit-learn
latent Dursley allocation or
non-negative matrix factorization I can
I can do this particular corpus in two
minutes with LD a about three minutes
with non-negative matrix factorization
or sixteen seconds with pls a alright so
I'm probably just cheating right because
I did something very fast and it's
garbage but it turns out that if you
measure the results it actually performs
better at modeling these documents than
either enemy if or Lda so P
they say is a good way to go but it
since unstable so what the problem here
is that these are hard optimization
problems we're solving a major problem
listing matrix factorization and topics
vary from one run to another you run it
twice you get a completely different set
of topics and now no one trusts the
topics you produce because you never get
the same thing twice how do we fix that
well the goal is to find the stable
topics what we can do is run it a whole
lot of times generate a whole lot of
topics from a whole lot of different
runs embed them with an emitting
technique cluster them with a clustering
algorithm and then you're getting just
the topics that recur a lot under lots
of rounds popping out as your clusters
you find the centroids of those clusters
or basically average those topics in
multinomial parameter space that's where
the topics live and the end result of
that is you get out of representative of
each topic of the each stable topic so
each cluster there is representing a
stable topic and as you can see from
this quick measure of whether this is
doing a good job or not it does actually
do a good job of boosting your
performance so what are you getting out
of this well you have greater stability
you run this multiple times you tend to
get pretty much the same topics out
every time they don't identical but
they're very similar it dramatically
determines the number of topics
automatically for you Lda you normally
hand it how many topics you want and it
gives you exactly that number this you
give a ballpark number and because it's
using clustering to find the number of
topics it'll give you more or at least
than that number but it's whatever
number actually occurs in the documents
and this is all embarrassing
embarrassing Lee parallel to run the
computation because we're just simply
running a whole big ensemble of these so
implementation I have written
implementation of exactly this approach
it has an a scaler an API so you can use
it right now it's on github here's where
to find it on github I'll give you a
second for that one in case you want to
write that down or just pip install in
stop and it'll work you can try it right
now thank you
Wow
all right I was pretty fast I feel
better
all right Annmarie you're up next
hi yeah so my name is Ann Marie Foster
I'm a UX researcher at Microsoft this
will probably be a really quick talk
because I didn't realize that this is
like a presentation thing but I just
wanted to talk to you guys about what I
do and how I'm here to help you so like
I said my roles of UX researcher I'm not
a data scientist but my role is to talk
to people and try to make your lives
easier
so that consists of like I do interviews
I do surveys I try to see how you guys
interact with products and where things
are missing or where they could be
better for you so um like I'm not a data
scientist I don't have something really
cool to show you but I just kind of
wanted to communicate to you that if you
guys have anything you want to share
with me um I really do just want to make
your lives easier even if you don't use
Microsoft products um my job is to
understand you guys what you guys are
doing where you guys are heading and how
that could all be better for you you may
have noticed the little whiteboard that
I have outside with like a bunch of
different magnets and icons that's just
a fun way of how I do research and I
hope to you know engage with all of you
and maybe connect with you later
yeah like I said quick talk I was not
expecting this
excellent if this keeps going this fast
I'm gonna get to talk really a lot at
the end you're all gonna love it it's
gonna be amazing
so Caitlyn you're up mat seal okay so my
name is Caitlyn Wilkinson and I'm a
designer at Microsoft and I work on the
developer tools design team I work with
anne-marie and Jeffrey on the Python
extension for vs code and for the past
like four or five months we've been
really focusing on a new native Jupiter
experience inside of es code when I
joined this team about six to seven
months ago we did it we didn't think it
was possible to have a need of Jupiter
view inside of es code and this is kind
of what it looked like so you had a
Python file on one side and then your
output on the other and we had all of
these
usability problems with our customers
like people are getting lost in their
file no one knew what to do or how to
use the product at all and then in about
July we realized that we could do a
native Jupiter experience and in October
we released this so now that we can have
native Jupiter support inside of the S
code so basically what we've done is
made our own UI inside of es code to go
in and load a notebook for you and just
play everything in line just like you
would for a regular Jupiter notebook
experience um but the funny thing about
this was that we couldn't use any of the
controls available to us in vs code we
had to build everything from scratch and
we had to work with about two other
teams to make sure that we were creating
a cohesive experience with other
Microsoft products um kind of like what
Amory was saying earlier we've been
doing with lots of research talking much
people it doesn't matter if you're using
our products or not we just want to know
like how you do what you do and that's
been like a main thing for us and so
we're pretty new it's pretty new part of
our tool and we have a long ways to go
but check it out it's pretty excited
about it yeah very cool nobody's having
to get applauded off the stage I'm I'm
really deeply impressed with everybody's
discipline I don't have that so well boy
we have met and then we have the last
lightning speaker who signed up Chris
Ariza perfect all right we're gonna do
the cardinal sin of presentations and do
some live coding so all right my name is
Mathew seal and do I have the wrong
thing oh no you can't see my screen I'm
gonna talk about scrapbook scrapbook is
a little library that I pulled out of
paper mill back a year or so ago and it
hasn't got a lot of love in the past six
months for me but now I'm back so I'm
working on it again and I'm gonna show
you what it does and why it was made
alright so we're gonna start with the
inability to click on my browser tab
no no no I can't open anything all right
one thing all right scrapbook is a
project which lets you I will show you
what the code would do and if I can get
it run anything I will I'm so sorry all
right so a scrapbook lets you do this
import you can basically save data so it
adds the ability to programmatically
save and recall data from notebooks so
if you think of notebooks this kind of a
function you only the outcome is always
a notebook you can't ask for the data
that came out of the notebook so
scrapbook lets you save the data by
using this glue function and you can
glue data into a notebook and then yeah
we take the metaphor a little far and
then down here you have a you can even
put images which if this were running
right now which it's not
you can rent it images and save them at
the same time and then in the result
reader which I cleared conveniently so I
could show how it ran before this you
could recall the code here so you can
read the notebook and then you can get
all the things that were saved in it and
go reiterate them so I can print out
what the data was for that list argument
that I saved which would be a list of
one two three and then I can get the
actual data as data and not as text or
as a JSON blob and then I can also grab
the image back out and I can call us dot
reglue which saves the image back into
the notebook so I can go fetch an image
I can save images as outcomes and then
recall them and collect them in some
other place and then the cool thing and
the experimental branch which I was
going to show you is in the experience
branch you can support pandas directly
so you can save pandas dataframes and
they recall them and it'll bring them
back through saving them as ut base64
arrow and then the other thing you get
is it'll have support for saving the
data in s3 instead of in the notebook
document so you can save a reference to
your data in s3 and recall that
reference and then I had a great little
part down here that showed that I pulled
the list from s3 and that the list was
over here actually I can show you what
saved in s3 so we got this dict see how
i saved it in s3 that was what I had in
my notebook when I said store this in s3
and put it into my user directory over
here
so if you want later after I unplug this
HDMI cable and kill Chrome I'll show you
how it actually runs so thank you oh
also contributors welcome it's open
project aren't a lot of contributors yet
so very cool I actually want that to
work because I need that for my life I'm
not kidding I'm serious like the ability
to export like a graph and a pandas
thing and then show that to a product
manager delicious so last we have Chris
Ariza
great hi my name is Chris Teresa and
I'll be talking to you today about the
best defense is not a defensive copy so
I do a lot of work in table-based
processing systems and as part of my
work I review a lot of code by my
colleagues where they are working
extensively in pandas and what I observe
often is a fear of unintentional
mutation leading to defensive copying so
what is there to fear well pandas
objects are mutable in place values can
be mutated or reordered in place indices
can be reassigned or mutated in place
making defensive copies of pandas
objects is a common solution so what's
wrong with defensive copies well they're
expensive in but in terms of both time
and space and can result in less
predictable performance depending on
what code paths happen to work through
your code so some fear is warranted side
effects lead to bugs it is well known
that for example a function that mutates
its arguments can lead to some very bad
behaviors if the argument is reused
downstream functions will get a change
result a class that has mutable
attributes that were intended to be read
only if a client mutates those
attributes different clients are going
to get different results and that can
cause really hard to understand bugs so
we'll get two examples of code extracted
from my colleagues I've simplified and
extracted them here where we see the
sphere of mutation leading to defensive
copies so in this example we have a
function that is we see this function
called processor which is taking
functions which is an iterable of
functions and those functions are being
called in a loop and each time they're
being called they're given this diction
arrey of previous results called results
here and as you can see the results are
being copied every time they're put into
this function and my colleague took this
approach because he was concerned naive
user riding one of these functions would
mutate the arguments and understanding
the negative consequences of that copied
the entire bundle of inputs every time
this thing loops around which as you can
imagine is very expensive another
example is a case where a colleague was
creating a class that was to serve as
interface to data here I've created
something very simple and lightweight
but the data is stored in the real case
was much bigger where the data is
created at initialization and then some
properties are made available to
retrieve those data as you can see here
the property is copying the data every
time the attribute is accessed so a
naive user of this class may just think
they can use this property but every
time they're using it they're actually
getting to copy out and as you can
imagine this can be very expensive so
what's better than defensive copies well
we can make arrays immutable and there's
two approaches we can do that so one
approach is to simply use numpy instead
of pandas when we need immutability and
we can do this because numpy arrays
implement the buffer protocol as defined
and Pep three one one eight which dates
back to 2006 there we see and in numpy
we see that the numpy array has a flags
and a writable attribute that permits
making arrays immutable so let's look at
an example if we create a numpy array of
integers here we create an array of 10
integers typically with a numpy array we
can mutate a value here I assign
negative 3 to index 4 and as you can see
the array is mutated but I can tweak the
flags looking at the flags you can see
all the flags available and I can simply
set the flags not writable to false and
now the array is immutable
you can try to assign there and you'll
get a convenient err this is a good
defensive move however using numpy alone
is challenging as you all know there are
no labeled axes automatic alignment of
data on labels doesn't happen there
isn't good missing value handling
which leads ones to consider if only
there was a pandas like tool that
managed immutable numpy arrays and there
is it's called static frame static frame
is an immutable alternative to pandas it
has many similar features with more
strict and consistent interface and what
it does is automatically manage
immutable numpy arrays so for example in
static frame we can create a series it's
very much like a Panda series and here
I'm creating a series of five values
with in with character character index
so in static frame we can try to assign
to a position in this series and we'll
get an exception and we'll say well this
this object doesn't support item
assignment well many of you know well
that's just easy I can just work around
that I'll just go to the underlying
array and I'll mutate the array but yet
if you try to do this again we find an
exception the array has been made
read-only so static frame has been in
development for over two years
it's deployed and actively used at
research affiliates and we're looking
for feedback we're looking for features
questions and PRS you can find this on
github you can pip install it it's ready
to go right now and we'd love to hear
from you
thank you
[Applause]